- [Instructor] Let's look
at two different methods
for preparing buffer solutions.
In the first method,
we're gonna add an aqueous solution
of a strong base, sodium hydroxide,
to an aqueous solution of
a weak acid, acetic acid.
Our goal is to calculate the
pH of the buffer solution
that forms when we mix these
two aqueous solutions together.
Our first step is to
figure out how many moles
of acetic acid that we have.
So if we have 100 milliliters
of a 1.00 molar solution
of acetic acid, we can use the equation:
molarity is equal to
moles divided by liters
to figure out the moles of acetic acid.
Since the concentration is 1.00 molar
and the volume is 100 milliliters,
which is equal to 0.100 liters,
x is equal to 0.100 moles of acetic acid.
We can do a similar calculation
to determine the moles of strong base.
So for our aqueous solution
of sodium hydroxide,
we have 50 milliliters of it
at a concentration of 1.00 molar.
So we plug in the concentration 1.00 molar
into the equation for molarity,
and we plug in the volume,
and 50 milliliters is
equal to 0.050 liters.
So solving for x,
we find the x is equal to 0.050
moles of sodium hydroxide.
Since sodium hydroxide is a strong base,
it dissociates completely in solution.
Therefore, if we have 0.050
moles of sodium hydroxide,
we also have 0.050 moles of
sodium cations in solution
and also hydroxide anions in solution.
When these two aqueous
solutions are mixed,
we're mixing 100 milliliters
with 50 milliliters
for a total volume of 150 milliliters.
Let me just go ahead
and write that down here really quickly.
And when the two solutions are mixed,
the acetic acid will react
with hydroxide anions
to form the acetate anion and water.
To figure out what's left over
after the reaction goes to completion,
we're gonna use an ICF table,
where I stands for initial,
C is for change, and F is for final.
We've already calculated
the initial number of moles
of acetic acid is equal to 0.100,
and the initial number of
moles of hydroxide anions
is equal to 0.050.
And if we assume the
reaction hasn't happened yet,
the initial number of
moles of the acetate anion
would be zero.
For this reaction,
the hydroxide anion is
the limiting reactant.
And therefore, we're gonna
use it all up in the reaction.
So we write -0.050 under
hydroxide in our ICF table.
Looking at the balanced equation,
the mole ratio of a acetic
acid to hydroxide anion
is one-to-one.
Therefore, if we are losing
0.050 moles of hydroxide anions,
we're also losing 0.050
moles of acetic acid.
So when the reaction goes to completion,
all of the hydroxide
anions have been used up.
Therefore, we have zero moles
of hydroxide anions left over.
For a acetic acid, if
we started with 0.100
and we're losing 0.050,
half of the acetic acid
has been neutralized
by the hydroxide anions,
and we're left with 0.050 moles
when the reaction goes to completion.
For the acetate anion,
the coefficient in the
balanced equation is a one.
Therefore, if we're losing 0.050
on the left side of the equation,
we're gonna be gaining
0.050 on the right side.
So when the reaction goes to completion,
we have 0.050 moles of the acetate anion.
A buffer solution consists
of significant amounts
of a weak acid and its conjugate base.
Acetic acid is a weak acid
and its conjugate base
is the acetate anion.
Therefore, the addition of
the strong base, hydroxide,
which neutralized half of the acetic acid
created a buffer solution
because we have significant
amounts of both acetic acid
and its conjugate base, the
acetate anion, in solution.
Remember that our goal
was to calculate the pH
of this buffer solution.
So first, we need to
calculate the concentration
of acetic acid and of the acetate anion.
To find the concentration of acetic acid,
we take the moles of acetic
acid which is equal to 0.050,
and we divide by the
total volume of solution.
We already calculated
when we mix the two solutions together,
the total volume was 150 milliliters
which is equal to 0.150 liters.
So 0.050 moles divided by 0.150 liters
gives the concentration of
acetic acid a 0.33 molar.
For the acetate anion,
we also have 0.050 moles,
and the total volume of
solution is also 0.150 liters.
Therefore, the concentration
of the acetate anion
is also 0.33 molar.
To find the pH of the buffer solution,
we can use the
Henderson-Hasselbalch equation.
The Henderson-Hasselbalch equation
says the pH of the buffer solution
is equal to the pKa of the weak acid
plus the log of the ratio
of the concentration
of the conjugate base
divided by the concentration
of the weak acid.
The weak acid present in our
buffer solution is acetic acid.
And at 25 degrees Celsius,
the pKa value of acetic
acid is equal to 4.74.
The acetate anion is our conjugated base
and it has a concentration of 0.33 molar,
so we can plug that into the
Henderson-Hasselbalch equation,
and the concentration of our weak acid
is also 0.33 molar.
Molars cancel and 0.33 divided
by 0.33 is equal to one.
And the log of one is equal to zero.
Therefore, for this buffer solution,
the pH is just equal to 4.74.
And notice that even though I
calculated the concentration
of the weak acid and
of the conjugate base,
I didn't really have to,
if you look at the
Henderson-Hasselbalch equation.
Because we have concentration
divided by concentration,
and concentration, molarity,
is moles per liter.
And so it's moles divided
by liters, divided by moles,
divided by liters.
And since both the weak
acid and the conjugate base
have the same total volume of solution,
the total volume of solution would cancel.
And so, if we want to,
we could just do a ratio of the moles
and we would have gotten the same answer,
a final pH of 4.74.
Let's look at another method
for making a buffer solution.
In this case, we're gonna
mix an aqueous solution
of a weak base with an aqueous solution
that contains the conjugate
acid to the weak base.
In this example, our weak
base is ammonia, NH3.
The conjugate acid to ammonia
is the ammonium ion, NH4+.
And if we have an aqueous
solution of ammonium chloride,
in solution, there are
ammonium ions, NH4+.
So we have a weak base, NH3,
and its conjugate acid, NH4+.
And when the two aqueous
solutions are mixed,
we'll have a significant
amount of both our weak base
and its conjugate acid.
Therefore, we will have a buffer solution.
I often say that a buffer
solution consists of a weak acid
and its conjugate base.
In this case,
I've said the buffer solution
consists of a weak base
and its conjugate acid.
So a more general definition
for a buffer solution
could be a weak conjugate acid-base pair.
We can calculate the pH of
the buffer solution that forms
when we mix the two solutions together
using the Henderson-Hasselbalch equation.
In this case,
our numerator is our weak
base which is ammonia
and our denominator is the
conjugate acid to ammonia
which is the ammonium ion, NH4+.
The ammonia solution had a
concentration of 0.16 molar,
and when we mix 100 milliliters
of the ammonia solution
with 100 milliliters of the
solution of ammonium chloride,
the total volume would double.
So we went from 100
milliliters to 200 milliliters.
Therefore, since we're
doubling the volume,
we're halving the
concentration of ammonia.
So we can put in 0.080 molar
for the concentration of ammonia.
Ammonium chloride is a soluble salt.
Therefore, if we have 0.20 molar
for the initial concentration
of ammonium chloride,
we have 0.20 more for
the initial concentration
of ammonium ions.
And since we're doubling the volume
when we mix the two solutions together,
we are halving the concentration.
So the concentration
of ammonium ions in
solution is 0.10 molar.
So we could plug that
into the Henderson-Hasselbalch equation.
So here we have the
concentrations plugged in,
0.080 molar is the
concentration of ammonia
and 0.10 molar was the
concentration of the ammonium ion.
In the Henderson-Hasselbalch equation,
the pKa is the pKa value of the weak acid,
which is the ammonium ion, NH4+.
At 25 degrees Celsius,
the pKa value of the ammonium
cation is equal to 9.25.
Molar cancels and when we solve
for the pH of the solution,
the pH is equal to 9.15.
So this problem started with a weak base
and a salt that contained
the conjugate acid
to that weak base.
It's also possible to
make a buffer solution
starting with an aqueous
solution of a weak acid
and adding a salt that
contains the conjugate base
to that weak acid.
For example, to make another buffer,
we could have started
with a solution of a
weak acid, acetic acid,
and to that solution,
we could have added something
like sodium acetate.
Sodium acetate is a soluble salt
that dissociates completely in solution
to produce sodium cations
and acetate anions.
And since we would have
a significant amount
of both a weak acid
and its conjugate base,
we would have a buffer solution.